hi i'm vivek kindra from the ibm cloud
hyper protect services team
today we are going to talk about
confidential computing as
provided by hyper protect so why
confidential computing
data security and protection are by far
the biggest inhibitors for organizations
seeking to move
sensitive applications and data to the
public cloud
in fact 95 percent of our customers
in regulated industry cited security
privacy
regulatory concern and cloud provider
having a back door access to
organization sensitive data as their
main inhibitors for using a public cloud
to address these concerns we are talking
about three pillars of data security
when considering end-to-end data
protection
data at rest and data in flight are the
two pillars
that historically have received the most
attention
and addresses many concern however
when regulated industry clients bring
their sensitive workloads to the ibm
cloud
hyper protect services they want to
process
their sensitive data with highest level
of data protection
without compromising the performance and
latency
so to complete the data protection
lifecycle clients wants to protect their
data when it is in use
or in memory this is the focus of
confidential computing
the ibm cloud hyper protect services
including crypto service
virtual server and databases service
offer protection to
all three pillars thereby providing an
end-to-end confidential computing
environment
in the ibm cloud so how does ibm provide
this level of security
well the hyperprotect services leverage
many years of ibm security and privacy
experience to the cloud
to do this we deploy our services on a
spatial linux one hardware
that utilizes what is known as a secure
service container
this is a protective boundary around the
base operating system management
back-end
and the application interface to ensure
no
access by the unauthorized figures like
system administrator
or the cloud providers secure service
container
ensure two things data integrity and
self-attestation
there is a temper protection and
verification through signatures
that the package software image is
deployed from a trusted source
and not being modified since leaving the
vendor
in case any temper is detected secure
service container will not boot that
image
there are several examples of client
segment from financial institutes
automotive manufacturer to startups who
are currently using hyperprotect
services
to achieve confidential computing today
we are going to explore one particular
use case the digital asset platform
with this use case clients are
tokenizing
and trading assets similarly to how the
stock market works
however the assets are not shares of a
company
they can range from coins to commodities
with our digital asset platform you have
the asset itself
that is run by a combination of three
things
a base technology blockchain that
provides the ledger
the wallets to protect the keys and
exchange
or the digital marketplace to provide a
confidential computing environment
for the digital asset platform first
we utilize protected runtimes with hyper
protect virtual servers
to actually run the application these
run within a secure service container
that automatically encrypts data and
provide memory protection
to ensure that no unauthorized person
gets access to secure data
next we work with hyper protect crypto
services to utilize the hardware
security module
or hsm and the key management service
with this technology
built on fips 140-2 level 4
certified hardware clients can lock down
their storage
backup secure service container and
applications
finally we work with ibm cloud offering
to provide backups
and storage also integrated with crypto
service and holistically
locking down the entire environment in
this way
we protect from malicious actors in
several ways
they cannot ssh into the boundary the
wallet
and the ledgers are stored in cold
storage or offline
with encrypted communication and the
secure service container is tamper proof
and will prevent unauthorized access
through these bad doors
so with that example in mind there are
two reasons to choose hyper protect
for confidential computing first client
maintains complete authority over their
workloads
they have exclusive control of who sees
the data
what happens to that data and how that
data is processed
second client data and applications are
protected from both
insider and outsider threads there is a
technical assurance
not just an operational assurance we go
beyond confidential computing
environment
to protect data at all stages in flight
at rest and in use plus the complete
authority that
only comes with ibm cloud with that
thank you for listening to this brief
overview of ibm cloud hyper protect
services
and their role in confidential computing
environment
do not forget to check us out at the
links below